recent work that we've done on the
building has really again operated from
two is two major considerations one is
how the building sits in the city you
know its scale its size its relationship
to you know its volumetric its urban
presence and trying to respond to
concerns that have been expressed about
it fitting in is it too high is it too
because it too is in the right place I
think was very important for us to inch
you know insure ourselves and everybody
else that the building you know what's
in the building do we have the right
things in the building they organized
well enough and convincingly enough for
us to be secure that we need this size
of building because if if the public is
not convinced that the building needs to
be this big then they're gonna ask more
questions about let's go if there's a
sense well we trust that this is what a
noble center needs in the same way that
if it was a railway station no one would
say can't you make a smaller railway
station one said well I presume that the
railway planners know how big it needs
to be obviously the public building
isn't quite so scientifically or
determined but you know there there is a
point where the activities that need to
come together to sustain the life of
this building and the concept of the
building requires a certain volume and
requires a certain surface so I think we
shook that tree very hard just to make
sure that we we weren't being wasteful
we weren't being lazy in terms of and it
so I think the the new improved
version is a consequence of really
scrutinizing the project interestingly I
mean sometimes when you scrutinize a
design especially that's done under
competition circumstances there can be a
tendency for it to collapse and certain
assumptions to disappear and be replaced
completely in this project I would say
the scrutiny has tended to reinforce
most of the decisions at work were there
before so it hasn't really collapsed I
think we managed to make it more compact
we've made it lower
we made it shorter I think it's it's
better in the city and I think nearly
more importantly I think we've worked
very hard with no belt to define really
the program and how this building might
perform and what it needs to do and how
it might assume its daily life
you